Okay, guys, we're going to do it. We're going to do one more episode. That's it. This is our last episode. Listeners, this is our final episode ever of Smartless. Right before we do the next one. That's right. But this is it.
好吧，伙计们，我们要开始了。我们要再录一期节目。就这样。这是我们的最后一期。听众们，这是我们有史以来最后一期《Smartless》了。就在我们录下一期之前。没错。但就是这样。
This is the last one before the next one. This one. Goodbye until the next one. When does it start? It's going to start right now. So hello. And goodbye. No, hello.
这是下一期之前的最后一期。这一期。在下一期之前，再见。它什么时候开始？马上就要开始了。所以，你好。再见。不，你好。
Until the next one. It's an all-new smartless. Until the next one. Smartless. What time is it there? just ate i had a piece of cod and i had some potatoes and some asparagus so cod that's uh that's british that's what they do the fish and chips with right that's right i had a cinnamon roll yeah i'll bet yeah of course that's that's british for american food hey do you um are you just moving dinner earlier
直到下一期。这是一个全新的《Smartless》。直到下一期。Smartless。那里几点钟了？刚吃过，我吃了一块鳕鱼，还有一些土豆和一些芦笋。所以鳕鱼，那是，那是英国风味，他们做炸鱼薯条用的那种对吧？没错。我吃了一个肉桂卷。是啊，我敢说，是的，当然，那是美国食物的英国说法。嘿，你，嗯，你是把晚餐时间
and earlier into the day what's happening well but yeah well i do have it's funny because my day kind of starts now because l.a is just waking up so yeah meanwhile you've done done a full day of rehearsal already yeah yeah and some interviews in the morning and radio like photoshoot but aren't you when you say your day starts what are you doing yeah so after this then i go i'm writing something for something and then what do you i know i don't want to say it so are you trying your hand at screenwriting or writing a play or no i'm just we're kind of talking it out and writing what the characters are the development like the outline and all that stuff okay yeah will does it taste good
越搬越早了吗？怎么回事？嗯，但，其实我有，这挺有意思的，因为我的一天差不多现在才开始，因为洛杉矶才刚刚醒来，所以，与此同时，你已经进行了一整天的排练了，对吧？对，对，早上还有一些采访、广播，比如拍照片。但你不是说你的一天开始了吗，你在做什么？对，所以在这之后，我要去为某个东西写点东西，然后，你——我不想说出来。所以你是在尝试写剧本或者写话剧吗？还是——没有，我只是，我们正在一起商量，写出角色的设定、大纲之类的东西。好吧，是的。威尔，这个好吃吗？
God does it sound. Fuck. Sorry. Sorry, I forgot. The gum. We're doing an audio show. I know. Who was the person who said, somebody said to me once,
天哪，这声音听起来。操。抱歉。抱歉，我忘了。口香糖。我们在做音频节目。我知道。是谁说过，有人曾经对我说过，
hey man, can you turn your gum down? That's a good one. It was so good. Sorry, I forgot. And Will, you're just getting started over there. Well, no, actually, you're midday right now. I'm midday. I was up this morning at 545.
嘿，老兄，你能把你的口香糖嚼小声点吗？这句太逗了。太逗了。抱歉，我忘了。威尔，你那边才刚开始。好吧，不，其实你现在正处于正午。我是正午。我今天早上5点45就起床了。
Don't need to brag. Isn't that wild? L.A., New York, London. All the same time. What's wild? Tell me what's wild. Different time zones? Talked about how wild.
不用显摆。这不是很疯狂吗？洛杉矶、纽约、伦敦。都在同一时间。什么很疯狂？告诉我什么很疯狂？有时差？谈论这有多疯狂。
Let's talk about it. Wait, Sean, no, sorry. What is it? Oh, it's Will. What did you do so, like, since 5.30, you're seven hours into your day. So I woke up this morning. I did my turtle-wirtle-curdle-curdle that used to be a part of with our old buddies.
我们来聊聊吧。等等，肖恩，不，抱歉。是什么？哦，是威尔。你到底做了什么，比如，从5点30开始，你的一天已经过去七个小时了。所以今天早上我醒了。我做了我的乌龟-乌龟-凝乳-凝乳，那以前是我们老伙计们的一部分。
You're still doing that? I'm still doing it every morning. I love it. And then I did. a hot cold. I did a sauna and then I did a cold plan for a few minutes. Then I went to my morning, my morning meeting. Gathering. Meeting. Very good.
你还在做那个？我每天都在做。我很喜欢。然后我做了。一个热冷交替。我蒸了个桑拿，然后做了几分钟的冷水浴。然后我去参加了我的早会。聚会。会议。非常好。
With all my peeps. I had a little coffee, came back, drove able to work, came back, worked out, and now I'm here. Had to quickly something to eat, now I'm here. When did you shower? When did you shower? Oh, fuck, I knew there was something. Yeah. I know. I'm going to do it after because it's just me in this sticky little booth.
跟我所有的伙伴们。我喝了一小杯咖啡，然后回来，开车去上班，回来，锻炼，现在我在这。赶紧吃点东西，现在我在这。你什么时候洗澡的？你什么时候洗澡的？哦，操，我知道有这么一出。对。我知道。我待会儿再洗，因为在这个黏糊糊的小录音亭里只有我一个人。
No, but you have... I didn't have time. I didn't have time. I literally just finished. I went upstairs. I had some leftover chicken salad. All I'm figuring out from this is that the workout was light. It was not, it was not light. I'll guarantee you that. Well, then why haven't you showered? You weren't a sweaty fucking mess. Of course I didn't have time. I didn't want to be late because we have a great guest. All right. But wait. Yes, go ahead. Oh, no, no, no. Get into it then.
不对，但是你——我没时间。我没时间。我真的是刚弄完。我上楼去。吃了一些剩下的鸡肉沙拉。我从这儿得出的唯一结论就是这次锻炼很轻松。一点也不，一点也不轻松。我向你保证。那为什么你没洗澡？你不是成了一个大汗淋漓的混蛋吗？我当然没时间。我不想迟到，因为我们有一位很棒的嘉宾。好吧。但是等等。是的，请说。哦，不，不，不。那就开始吧。
I do have a great guest. I do have a great guest. You guys are going to be really thrilled. And so I mean, our audience already knows because they looked at the thing when they logged on. knows what our audience already knows so as you're hearing going with your hair what's happening that's what happens um and the knees and the hips our our guest today he has built a career out of portraying uh some of the most unique and unforgettable characters in recent cinema i mean he's one of these guys who has alpuccino uh alpuccino uh burt reynolds is still around mccana hay is coming back he literally just said one sentence all better all better i i i think our guest is i think our guest is laughing uh how absurd that is al pacino out of the blue that haven't even named him um he's been nominated for golden
我的确有一位很棒的嘉宾。我的确有一位很棒的嘉宾。你们一定会非常兴奋。所以，我的意思是，我们的观众已经知道了，因为他们登录的时候看了那个东西。知道我们的观众已经知道了，所以当你听到时，你的头发怎么了？发生了什么？这就是发生的，嗯，还有膝盖和臀部，我们今天的嘉宾，他通过塑造电影中一些最独特、最令人难忘的角色，建立了自己的职业生涯。我的意思是，他是那种有阿尔·帕西诺——阿尔·帕西诺——伯特·雷诺兹还在，马修·麦康纳要回来了。他刚才literally就说了一句话。全好了，全好了。我，我，我觉得我们的嘉宾，我觉得我们的嘉宾在笑，这有多荒谬，阿尔·帕西诺突如其来，他们甚至还没点他的名。他曾获得过金球
globes he's been the spirit awards here's froston critics awards you oh my god you know him you know him and he's done it all in in television and film some of the great some of the great Boardwalk Empire Steve Bouchemy Get him out here Sopranos Reservoir dogs Steve Boucheré
奖提名，他还获得过独立精神奖、弗罗斯特影评人奖。哦，天哪，你认识他，你认识他，而且他把电视和电影界的所有成就都揽于一身，其中一些伟大的，一些伟大的《大西洋帝国》史蒂夫·布西密把他请出来，《黑道家族》《落水狗》史蒂夫·布西密。
God you guys wouldn't let me finish for fuck sake You've got to bury You should have started with You can't name his stuff Because once you start naming everything he's done
天哪，你们刚才不让我说完，真他妈的。你得埋伏。你一开始就应该说，你不能直接报他的料，因为一旦你开始历数他演过的一切
You're like oh yes You start with some of the voiceover stuff You would have kept us in the dark Well if I'd started with the animated movies You're right One of the greatest voiceover artist Next to Will Arnette
你就会说，哦，是的。你得从一些配音作品开始。你本可以把我们蒙在鼓里。好吧，如果我从动画电影开始。你说得对。最伟大的配音演员之一，仅次于威尔·阿奈特。
That's right That's saying something Thank you That's saying very little. Monsters University. Yeah, there you go. I know, I know. Right?
没错。这话很有分量。谢谢。这分量可真轻。《怪兽大学》。对，这就对了。我知道，我知道。对吧？
What about Igor? Oh, Igor, right, Igor. Come on. We've worked together a lot and never really... Wait, what was eager now? I don't know if I knew Igor. It was an animated film from 17,000 years ago. Okay.
那《伊戈尔》呢？哦，伊戈尔，对，伊戈尔。拜托。我们合作过很多次，但从来没有真的——等等，伊戈尔是什么时候？我不知道我是否知道《伊戈尔》。那是17000年前的一部动画电影。好吧。
John Cusack. Yeah? Oh. Igor. Jennifer Coolidge, Molly Shannon. Yeah. And Sean, you played... What a cast.
约翰·库萨克。是吗？哦。伊戈尔。詹妮弗·库里奇，莫莉·香农。对。还有肖恩，你演了——多么强大的演员阵容。
Brian. You were the brain, but you spelled it. No, my name is Brian, right. Boy, if he was the brain, you guys were in trouble. I always challenge myself on that. Steve O'Shea, welcome to Smartless. God, it's good to have you here. This is great.
布莱恩。你是那个智囊，不过你是这么拼的。不，我的名字叫布莱恩，对。天哪，如果他是智囊，你们可就麻烦了。我总是喜欢在这方面挑战自己。史蒂夫·布西密，欢迎来到《Smartless》。天哪，你能来这里太棒了。这太棒了。
This is fantastic. I'm such a massive have been like everybody else of what you do, because you do so much different stuff. It's amazing. And so just to have you out here is I've got to say kind of a thrill. I'm thrilled to be here, guys. Thank you so much.
这太棒了。我是你作品的超级大粉丝，就像其他人一样，因为你演了那么多不同的角色。这太神奇了。所以你能来到这里，我得说，这简直是一种刺激。我很激动能来到这里，伙计们。非常感谢。
I'm really aghast right now I'm a little That I'm not Al Pacino How lucky are we I'm sorry Sean I was a shot in the dark It was a shot in the dark Steve where do we find you
我现在真的很震惊，我有点，我居然不是阿尔·帕西诺。我们有多幸运啊。对不起，肖恩，我只是瞎猜的。我只是瞎猜的。史蒂夫，我们在哪里能找到你？
Where's that beautiful orange room you're in? I'm in the Netflix building in New York Okay Oh hence the red background Yeah Orange Like adjust your
你在哪个美丽的橙色房间里？我在纽约的网飞大楼里。好吧。哦，难怪背景是红色的。对。橙色。就像调整你的
Sort of a soundproof room Yeah either that or the set squid game you're i was going to get to this but we can we can mention it early on you're working on it you got your your netflix show is coming out soon right wednesday uh yes the name of the show it's not coming out that's the name of the name of the name of it's the second season of uh the adams family show when wednesday that's right that's right uh which is which has been a huge success huge huge huge yeah i love the first season and i'm really excited that they cast me in the in the second season i played the new principal of nevermore that's the boarding school that um wednesday attends
某种隔音室。对，要么就是《鱿鱼游戏》的片场。我本来要说到这个的，但我们可以，我们可以早点提出来，你在拍这个，你的网飞剧集快要上映了，对吧？《星期三》。嗯，是的，剧名。还没上映呢。那是剧名，剧名的名字，名字就是——《亚当斯一家》衍生剧《星期三》第二季。没错，没错。这剧取得了巨大的成功。巨大，巨大，巨大。是的，我喜欢第一季，我非常高兴他们选我出演第二季。我饰演奈弗莫尔学院的新校长，那是——星期三上学的寄宿学校。
ah i see nice well you'd make you great principal i don't know um hey i think i do uh steve uh so we always ask people like how they got started whatever i've always wanted to know what was a young steve bouchemie like when you were a kid were you like seven years old you wanted to be an actor or kind of because i know that you had it you started with a different career professionally before you What was it? Can you walk us through that a little bit? Well, I mean, when I was a kid, you know, like all of us, I watched a lot of TV and it was everything. You know, it was like the Three Stooges, which, Sean, I have, again, I have to say, man, you played.
啊，我明白了。不错。嗯，你会成为一个好校长的。我不知道，嗯。嘿，我觉得我会，嗯，史蒂夫。所以我们总是问别人是如何开始的之类的问题。我一直想知道，年轻时的史蒂夫·布西密是什么样的？当你还是个七岁左右的孩子时，你想成为一名演员吗？还是因为我知道，你最初从事的是一份不同的职业，在专业上？那是什么？你能给我们简单介绍一下吗？好吧，我的意思是，当我还是个孩子的时候，你知道，和我们所有人一样，我看很多电视，什么都看。你知道，就像《三个臭皮匠》，肖恩，我，再次，我不得不说，老兄，你演过。
This was a picture. I can't believe you got to play laughing. Talk about a stooge. This guy was a perfected stooge. Go for casting. Three stooges were big in my house. my house in my apartment in east uh not my apartment in the apartment i lived in in east new york brooklyn uh yeah the little rascals you know yeah shows like that and then but also you know
这是一张照片。我真不敢相信你能扮演滑稽角色。说到臭皮匠，这家伙简直是一个完美的臭皮匠。去试镜吧。《三个臭皮匠》在我家很火。在我家，我在纽约布鲁克林东区住的公寓里——对，还有《小淘气》，你知道，对，诸如此类的节目，但还有，你知道的
like the afternoon uh movie that was on at like four o'clock you know like that would show all these gangster films you know so i was a big fan of cagney and bogart and all those films too but did you see yourself doing this because like i like i alluded to you you kind of started in a different career and Jason's not aware of this but but some people are and so when was the moment that you allowed yourself and just walk us through what that career was briefly if you don't mind if it's okay well I mean I was a firefighter in the early 80s wow really yeah but I had been trying to be an actor and actually I tried my hand to stand up so it's not like I you know was a firefighter who then decided to become an actor I was already you know
比如下午四点左右播出的那种电影，你知道，会播放所有这些黑帮电影，所以我也成了卡格尼和鲍嘉以及所有这些电影的超级粉丝。但你当时觉得自己会做这个吗？因为就像我刚才暗示的，你其实是从一份不同的职业开始的，杰森对此并不知情，但有些人知道。那么，当你允许自己尝试的时候，那个时刻是怎样的？如果你不介意的话，能简单跟我们讲讲那段职业生涯吗？如果可以的话。好吧，我的意思是，我在80年代初是一名消防员。哇，真的吗？对。但其实我一直在努力成为一名演员，事实上我还尝试过单口喜剧，所以并不是说我，你知道，是一个先决定成为演员的消防员。我当时已经是一个，你知道
kind of a flailing stand-up and wannabe actor who had taken the fire department test when I was 18, and they didn't get to my name. My name was on a list, and they called me when I was like, I was 22, I think, when I was called. And then I was like, I'm going nowhere with this showbiz stuff, so I joined the fire department. And you fought fires for four or five years, is that right?
有点混得不怎么样的单口喜剧演员和怀揣演员梦的人，我在18岁时参加了消防部门的考试，但没叫到我的名字。我的名字在一个名单上，他们打电话给我时，我大概，我22岁吧，我想，当时我接到电话。然后我想，我在这个演艺圈混不出什么名堂，所以我加入了消防部门。你灭了四五年火，是这样吗？
Yeah, I was at Engine 55. Manhattan. It's crazy. In New York? Yeah. In New York. Oh, my goodness. And it should be noted that you also rejoined briefly after 9-11.
对，我在55号消防站。曼哈顿。太疯狂了。在纽约？对。在纽约。哦，天哪。而且应该指出的是，在911事件后，你还短暂地重新加入了。
Is that true? I heard that. Well, I didn't rejoin. I just, I went down to my old firehouse on Broom Street because I knew that they were there, that they had been at the site, and I couldn't get any information. So on the 12th, I went there, and I brought my turnout gear, my coat and health. helmet and boots and gloves. That's amazing.
是这样吗？我听说过。嗯，我没有重新加入。我只是，我去了布鲁姆街我以前的消防站，因为我知道他们在那里，他们曾在现场，而我得不到任何消息。所以在12号，我去了那里，我带上了我的消防装备，我的外套、头盔、靴子和手套。太惊人了。
And I was brought into the site by another firefighter, and he told me about the guys that were missing in the company, and one was a good friend of mine. And anyway, I went down to the site, and I was able to find my company there. Because they had lost members, they had access to, like, the man. pile that that was you know still wow burning right and and
我被另一个消防员带到了现场，他告诉我公司里失踪的人，其中一个是我的好朋友。不管怎样，我去了现场，我在那里找到了我的消防队。因为他们失去了成员，他们可以进入那堆，你知道，仍然在燃烧的瓦砾，而且——
this is the day out I got to work with them you know for the rest of the week you know this was on a wow man and were these guys who kept kept in touch with and you were they still in the same
就是那天，我得以和他们一起工作，你知道的，在那剩下来的一个星期里，你知道，这是在——哇，老兄。这些是你一直保持联系的家伙吗？你还在同一个
no I mean there were some yeah I mean there were some guys that I recognized who I used to work with but by and large it was all new new guys and I didn't know them and but I got to know them during the week and since then i've stayed in touch and now every year on nine 11 um i
不，我的意思是，有一些，是的，我的意思是，有一些我认得的家伙，我以前跟他们一起工作过，但总的来说，全都是新面孔，我不认识他们。不过我在那一周里认识了他们，从那以后我一直保持着联系。现在每年911，我都
attend the uh the breakfast at the firehouse with the families and then there's a mass service and then there's a lunch and there's also bar time in there in their in their sure sure we do do we are they are firefighters yeah so there is a fair amount of uh drinking at tony's bar yeah that's incredible I mean, that's, and Sean, you've, you've supported, so you bought a calendar every year, right? Yeah, I bet. Steve had, I never miss the year.
会参加消防站的早餐会，和家属们一起，然后是一场弥撒，然后是午餐，中间还有去托尼酒吧喝酒的时间，在他们的，在他们的，当然，当然，我们去，他们是消防员吗？是的，所以在托尼酒吧有相当多的喝酒活动。是的，这太不可思议了。我的意思是，那是，肖恩，你，你一直支持，所以你每年都买一本挂历，对吧？是的，我敢说。史蒂夫有，我从来没有错过一年。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. I do what I can. I do what I can. Steve, how did firefighting find you at a young age? Was your dad involved with any of that stuff? My dad was a sanitation worker. He worked in Brooklyn, and he did that. for 30 years and so he was he just knew the civil service you know like like what like what that job
对，对，对，对，对。我尽力而为。我尽力而为。史蒂夫，消防工作是怎么在年轻时找到你的？你父亲做过这方面的工作吗？我父亲是一名环卫工人。他在布鲁克林工作，干了30年。
meant the benefits the whole apparatus that keeps that city moving yeah and you know the pay is good and you get good benefits and he always I mean he knew I wanted to become an actor but he would tell me you know just put in your 20 years and then you can do all the acting you want it doesn't really work that way but but I tried it because meanwhile you're 20 Put in your 20. Just put in your 20, retire at half pay, and then do all the acting you want. He was noticing that you were, you were leaning towards acting. Is that because you were taking classes as a young kid?
所以他很了解公务员体制，你知道，比如，这份工作意味着什么，福利，以及让这个城市运转的整套机构。是的，你知道，工资不错，福利也好，他总是——我的意思是，他知道我想成为一名演员，但他会告诉我，你知道，只要干满20年，然后你想怎么演戏就怎么演戏。其实不完全是那么回事，但我试过了。因为与此同时，你20岁了。干满20年。干满20年，拿一半的退休金退休，然后你想怎么演戏就怎么演戏。他注意到你有，你有倾向于演戏的苗头。是因为你从小就在上表演课吗？
Were you doing it at school? I mean, I think he kind of knew it that I had it in me since I was a little kid, because when I was really little, I used to just make up stories and tell jokes. if we were at a cousin's wedding I would like stand up on a table and just do like a stand-up routine I'm sure it was like stupid but I was like
你是在学校里演的吗？我的意思是，我想他差不多从小就知道我有这方面的天赋，因为当我真的很小的时候，我总是编造故事讲笑话。如果我们去表亲的婚礼，我会站到桌子上表演一段单口喜剧。我敢肯定那一定很蠢，但我当时大概
five or six so they and then I talk about this I've talked about this before when I was in fourth grade my teacher Mr. Rickabono he cast me in
五六岁，所以他们。然后我谈到过这个，我以前说过，当我上四年级的时候，我的老师里卡博诺先生让我出演
a production of the Wizard of Oz I got to play the Cowardly Lion and I thought this is it if I never do anything else after this I was so happy And when I was on stage I just, it was that feeling of Wow, people are enjoying this and they're laughing
了一部《绿野仙踪》。我演了胆小狮，当时我想，就是这个了，如果从此以后我再也没有做过别的事我也心满意足了。当我站在舞台上的时候，我就有那种感觉，哇，人们很喜欢这个，他们在笑。
And I'm, you know That'd be a good role for you, J.B. Yeah, cowardly lion. Yeah. I could do it. I could do it. He's got the hair for it. Wait, so.
而我，你知道。这倒挺适合你演的，杰森。对，胆小狮。是的。我能演。我能演。他有那个发型。等等，所以。
He does have the main. Who was, was mom or dad somebody who was outgoing and sort of a, who was who was leading for you at that moment? Like, who was your North Star? Was it mom or dad? dad you know i in in their own ways both i mean my mom was the one when we were young who used
他确实有那个鬃毛。是谁，妈妈还是爸爸是个性格外向的人，某种程度上，谁在那个时刻为你带路？谁是你的北极星？是妈妈还是爸爸？爸爸，你知道，他们各自有各自的方式。我的意思是，在我小的时候，我妈妈是那个经常
to take us to the movies and and and see musicals and and and and then when i was a teenager you know a little bit even younger my my dad would take us to the movies and we'd see things like across a hundred tenth street and cotton comes to harlem and movies i just shouldn't have been seeing like that you know and but but it was great yeah And my dad, he had a good friend growing up in East New York named Peter Miller, who became an actor. And he went to the neighborhood playhouse, and he was in movies with Cassavetes, and he was in Robert Altman's first film, The Delinquents. And then he, you know, but he did it for a few years, and then he left, and he became an investment banker.
带我们去看电影，看音乐剧，然后等我十几岁的时候，你知道，年纪还要再小一点的时候，我爸爸会带我们去看电影，我们会看一些像《110街交错点》和《棉花俱乐部》这样的电影，还有一些我根本不该看的电影，你知道的，但，但感觉真的很棒。是的。我爸爸在东纽约长大时有个好朋友叫彼得·米勒，后来成了一名演员。他去了邻里剧场，跟卡萨维蒂一起演过电影，还演了罗伯特·奥 Altman 的第一部电影《反叛者》。然后他，你知道的，他演了几年前，然后就离开了，成了一名投资银行家。
So by the time I, you know, was old enough to talk to him, he had left acting, but I still, you know, it was like, oh, Uncle Pete, and he lives in California, and I was like, someday I'm going to make it to California, and Uncle Pete's going to show me the ropes. Right. And so there was that, you know, so there was that. But really, you know, in junior high and high school, I didn't do any theater. I kind of became a jock and did sports. What were you playing? I played soccer and I, a little bit of track, but wrestling was my, you know, big sport that I really loved. And then it wasn't until my senior year that I started to, like, do the plays in high school.
所以等我，你知道的，长到能跟他对话的时候，他已经不演戏了，但我还是觉得，哦，皮特叔叔，他住在加州，当时我想，总有一天我要去加州，让皮特叔叔带带我。对。所以当时就是这样，你知道的，就是这样。但实际上，你知道的，在初中和高中时，我根本没演过话剧。我差不多变成了一个运动男孩，整天搞体育。你当时玩什么？我踢足球，还稍微练过田径，不过摔跤才是我的，你知道的，我真正热爱的核心运动。直到高三的时候，我才开始在高中里演话剧。
And I had another great teacher, Lynn Lappin. He was the English teacher, but he started the first acting class. And so I got to be in Fiddler on the roof and, you know, and just, it was really fun. That's cool. What was that first trip out to L.A. like? Was there one? Yeah, I... So Uncle Pete and Charlene, his wife, they lived in Van Nuys.
我又遇到了另一位伟大的老师，林·拉平。他是英语老师，但他发起了第一个表演班。所以我得以参演《屋顶上的提琴手》，你知道的，而且真的非常有趣。太酷了。你第一次去洛杉矶是什么体验？有过那样的经历吗？有，我……皮特叔叔和他的妻子夏琳，他们住在凡尼斯。
Yeah. Beautiful out there. So I stayed with them, but I didn't have a car. I didn't have a car, and he would go off to work, and I'd just be like, I want to see L.A. I didn't know, but I didn't know how to do it. like 115 degrees with no trees. So no car in Van Nuys.
是的。那里的风景美极了。所以我住在他们那儿，但我没有车。我没有车，他去上班了，而我就想，我想看看洛杉矶。我根本不懂，但我不知道该怎么逛。那里大概有115华氏度，而且一棵树也没有。所以在凡尼斯没有车。
So you just started hooping it and enjoying, you know, the fruits of Woodman Avenue and Woodman Sherman Way. But I think it was on that trip because I had done a film called Parting Glances in New York and I went out to L.A. to try and meet casting people. And my friend Kathy Kinney, who was in that, who was in that, who was. in that film she was taking meetings and she would just bring me along
于是你只好开始暴走，享受，你知道的，伍德曼大道和伍德曼谢尔曼路的种种风光。但我想正是在那次旅行中，因为我在纽约拍过一部叫《离别依依》的电影，我去了洛杉矶，想去见见选角导演。我的朋友凯西·金尼，她也参演了那部电影，她当时正在参加各种会面，她就把我带上了。
like she would pick me up and bring me along to these meetings and some people were okay like oh you brought a friend but he's really good actor you know you should see him too but mostly I think they were like who is this guy like why did you bring him
比如她会开车接我，把我带到这些会面现场，有些人还算好说话，比如，哦，你带了个朋友来，但他是个很棒的演员，你知道的，你也应该看看他，但大多数时候，我觉得他们的反应是，这人是谁啊？你干嘛把他带过来？
yeah that rarely goes down well they're like oh you well of course let's meet your friend and then so those first few experiences were they were you kind of freestyling or Were you coming with a certain amount of training that you were leaning on? No, I had no. I had no idea what I was doing.
是的，那种情况很少能顺利进行，他们会说，哦，你——当然，让我们见见你的朋友吧。所以那些最初的经历，你当时是在自由发挥，还是带着一定程度的表演训练作为依靠？不，我完全没有。我根本不知道自己在做什么。
Really, I just did not know. I remember when I first got a manager and I was going out on meetings and the feedback that he was getting was, you know, he's kind of so deadpan and he's like, he doesn't seem like he wants to be here. he just like is so quiet and like so it's good
真的，我完全没有头绪。我记得我刚签了经纪人开始去面试时，他收到的反馈是，你知道的，他这人太面无表情了，感觉他根本不想待在这里，他话太少太安静了，所以——很好。
so then I went to I remember the first time I met Bonnie Timmerman you know big casting agent I went in and I went in smiling and the first thing she said to me
然后我去见——我记得我第一次见邦妮·蒂默曼，你知道的，那个大选角导演，我走了进去，脸上带着微笑，她对我说第一句话是：
was what are you smiling for well now I don't know what to do like right she thought I was like laughing at something I was like no I was told to smile so I'm sorry come in there looking crazy that's funny
你笑什么笑？好吧，现在我不知道该怎么办了，就像——对吧？她以为我在笑话什么东西，我说，不，有人告诉我进来要笑，所以对不起，我看起来像个疯子，真搞笑。
and we will be right back and now back to the show so you kind of figure it out though like you do you do a bunch of different parts I mean you do sort of like eight ten movies maybe before reservoir dogs and you do a bunch of
我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以你算是摸索出门道了，你会接拍各种各样的角色，我是说，在《落水狗》之前你大概拍了差不多八到十部电影，你演了很多
varying degree bigger bigger roles and etc what was but that must have been kind of a seminal moment if I'm guessing right. And talk a little bit about how that came into your world and what it was like first meeting Quentin Tarantino. So the script came to me from one of my early agents, Nancy Green,
戏份多少不一、越来越重的角色等等。不过那一定是个意义重大的时刻，如果我没猜错的话。谈谈那部电影是如何进入你的世界的，以及你第一次见到昆汀·塔伦蒂诺是什么感觉。剧本是一个叫南希·格林的早期经纪人拿给我的，
who has since passed away. But she was really great. And I have to back up the story because like a year before that, or maybe six months before that, she convinced me to go on an audition for, it was a Neil Simon in comedy and I don't remember I don't even remember what film it was for but I
她现在已经去世了。但她人真的很好。我得把故事倒回一点，因为在那之前大约一年，或者也许六个月前，她极力劝我去试镜一个尼尔·西蒙的喜剧，我不记得了，我甚至不记得那是部什么电影了，但我
really didn't want to go and she said no just go you can meet the casting director Ronnie Eskoll and just you know I want okay I went and there were other actors there and they put us in like a group scene we were improvising and it
真的不想去，她说不，去吧，你可以见见选角导演罗妮·埃斯科尔，然后，你知道的，我想好吧。我就去了，那里还有其他演员，他们把我们分到一个小组场景里，我们在即兴表演，那
was fun and then but you know I left and I didn't get the you know whatever part that I was auditioning for and uh forgot about about it and then i got the script for reservoir dogs from nancy and i loved it and um and i for the i didn't you know the first time i met quentin was on the phone and hearing his voice i was just shocked because i thought i was going to be talking to like an ex-convict who was like in his 50s or something and instead it was like hey man thanks for reading my script thanks a bunch i'm really
挺有意思的，然后呢，你知道的，我离开了，也没有得到，你知道的，我试镜的那个什么角色，然后就把这事给忘了。接着我从南希那里拿到了《落水狗》的剧本，我非常喜欢，而且，我第一次见昆汀是通过电话，听到他的声音时我简直惊呆了，因为我以为我会跟一个像是什么五十岁左右的前囚犯之类的人说话，结果却是：“嘿，哥们，谢谢你读我的剧本，非常感谢，我真的
excited. And I was like, wait, is this, are you Quentin Tarantino? Yeah, yeah, man. You know, I was like, it just didn't match up. And, but he was so excited and so, and so enthused. And I auditioned for it twice. And then I did the workshop for it in Sundance. And it was Quentin and I, and this is, I guess, typical Quentin fashion. He tells me I got the part of Mr. Pink as we were in the bathroom we're in the bathroom together and he said oh by the way I cast you as Mr. Pink
很兴奋。”我说，等等，这是——你是昆汀·塔伦蒂诺吗？“对，对，哥们。”你知道的，我就觉得，这根本对不上号。但他极其兴奋，极其热情。我为这部电影试镜了两次。然后我在圣丹斯做了剧本排练。那是昆汀和我，我想这大概是昆汀式的典型作风，他在洗手间里告诉我，我得到了“粉先生”这个角色，当时我们俩正在洗手间里，他说：“哦，对了，我选你演粉先生。”
I went out what what oh really? He says yeah and he says yeah and it wasn't really based on your audition you know he said but Ronnie Eskill showed me
我当时说，什么？什么？哦，真的吗？他说：“对啊。”他说：“对啊，其实这并不是完全根据你的试镜表现决定的，”你知道的，他说，“不过罗妮·埃斯科尔给我看了你在试镜那个尼尔·西蒙电影时的录像。”那可是一部喜剧啊，你在我身上看到了什么才觉得……他说：“因为你当时穿着一件复古衬衫，头发往后梳，
a tape of when you audition for that Neil's Simon movie but that was a comedy like what did you see in me that you thought he goes well because you had on like a vintage shirt and your hair was slicked back
看起来就像个罪犯。”而那其实正是我当时的日常穿搭，那只是我刚从床上爬起来的德行，真的假的。所以感谢上帝我去了那次试镜，你知道的。
and you look like a criminal and that was just how I dressed that was just me just rolling out of bed yeah no way and so thank God I went on that audition you know yeah
没错。
yeah that's cool isn't that amazing how those things kind of worked like that you just never know it is and was that was that would you
太酷了，那些事情竟然会那样发展，真是不可思议，你永远猜不到。确实如此。那部电影，或者说那前后的一些电影，你会不会说
would you say that that film or any of the films around that started to solidify for you what you what you were confident in doing and I guess the question is at what point did you start to really kind of just dig into your style quote unquote or or what your confidence was you know what I have is going
它们开始帮你巩固了你擅长的领域，或者你对自己的表演有了信心？我想问的是，你从什么时候开始真正深入摸索出自己的“所谓风格”，或者说建立起那种自信——你知道，你拥有的东西是行得通的，你拥有能让你谋生并获得创作满足感的东西？你是从什么时候开始产生这种感觉的：我拥有他们所需要的东西，而且我喜欢他们找我来演这类角色？我是说，那部电影《落水狗》对打开局面绝对起到了很大作用。它对我的自信心提升很大，单单是被选上这一点。能跟哈维·凯特尔一起拍电影，还能跟哈维演对手戏，你知道的，那简直就像做梦一样。我从来没想过那会成为现实。而且还能去见识、合作像蒂姆·罗斯和迈克尔·马德森这样的演员——我们不幸失去了后者——
to work what I have is going to take me into something that I can make a living and also can be creatively fulfilled like when did you get that feeling of I've got what I what I think it takes and I and I like that they're hiring me for this type of thing I mean, that film, Reservoir Dogs, had a lot to do with opening doors for sure. And it did a lot for my confidence, just being cast. Being cast in a movie with Harvey Keitel and having scenes with Harvey was, you know, that was like a dream. I never thought that that would be possible. And then getting to meet, you know, and work with actors like Tim Roth and Michael Mattson, who we sadly lost.
还能见到埃迪·邦克，他曾是个前囚犯，写过电影《直奔地狱》（根据他的书改编）和《暴走列车》。所以能跟这些人以及克里斯·佩恩还有整个剧组在一起，让人感到无比兴奋。因此，仅仅是拍了这部电影，就是一个巨大的自信心加持。然后，你知道的，昆汀通过那个演职员表序列给了我们所有人一个巨大的恩惠，让我们在停车场里走动，
and meeting Eddie Bunker, who was an ex-convict and wrote the movie straight time that was based on his book and runaway train. And so it was just exciting to be with these people and Chris Penn and the whole cast. So just having done the movie was a huge confidence boost. And then, you know, Quentin did us all a big favor by that credit sequence of having us, you know, walk in the parking lot
我们的名字就在我们脸部的下方，随着我们的走动而出现。因为在这之前，大家的反应都是：这小子是谁？这谁啊？你知道的，如果当时提到我的名字，你根本无法把脸和名字对号入座。确实如此。现在至少人们可以了。而且我有了可以展示的东西，你知道的，如果我争取某个角色，而他们想看看我演过什么，那部电影就是答案。
and our names were underneath our faces, like as we're walking. Because before that, it was like, who's this guy? Who's, you know, like if my name was mentioned, you know, you couldn't put a face to the name. Sure. Now, at least people could. And I had something to show, you know, like if I was up for something and they wanted to see what I did, that was the film.
对的。所以那确实打开了局面。但至于我的风格到底是什么之类的东西，我从来都说不准，你知道的，我觉得自己演过太多完全不同类型的作品了。根据我遇到的人——你知道的，比如如果在街上被认出来，我永远不知道他们是因为《严肃的男人》（注：此处或指其他柯恩兄弟电影）、塔伦蒂诺还是亚当·桑德勒才认识我，你知道的，所以有些人只在喜剧的层面认识我，而其他人则是通过其他作品认识我的。嗯，这正是对你职业生涯的最好赞誉。
Yeah. And so that opened doors. But I, you know, as far as what my style is or anything, I'm, I never know, you know, I feel like I've done so many different kinds of things. And depending on like who I meet, you know, like on the street if I get recognized, I never know what they, you know, is it from a Coen Brothers, is it from Tarantino or is it from Adam? Yeah. Sandler, you know, so some people only kind of know me in that comedic vein and other people know me. from other things. Well, that's a tribute to your career.
我是说，你能把那么多不同类型的作品都演得这么好。在你面前，有时一定有大量的选择。你是如何决定自己接下来的发展方向的？是基于参与的演员阵容吗？是基于角色的类型——也许要跟刚刚演过的上一个角色有所不同？你是如何做决定的？我想每次都不一样吧。有时候是因为剧本实在太精彩了，
Like, I mean, you're able to do so many different things so well. It must be, you must have a great number of choices in front of you at times. And how do you decide which way you're going to go? Is it based on the people involved? Is it based on the kind of character, that being maybe different than the last one you just played? How are you making your decisions? I guess it's different each time. Sometimes it's just such a wonderful script
如果这是一部独立电影，而且是一个崭露头角的年轻电影人，我非常喜欢做那种类型的工作。哦，天哪。而有时则是，你知道的，取决于参与的人。但归根结底还是剧本本身。我是说，我总是把剧本放在第一位。
and if it's an independent film and it's a young filmmaker that's starting to come up and I love doing that type of work. Oh, wow. And then other times it is, you know, it's the people who are involved. But it really is the material. I mean, I try and go for the material first.
是整个剧本还是你特定的角色？整个剧本。我是说，以前有过这么一个阶段，当我读剧本时，他们问我演哪个角色，我直接就去翻页看那个角色什么时候会领便当。我发誓，有一次我拿到一个剧本……
The script as a whole or your particular character? As a whole. I mean, it used to be, there was a time when I would read a script and they'd say what character and I would just flip the pages to see when the character would be killed. I swear it was a script that.
哦，我撑到了第39页。好吧。我想我接了。那会是那种角色领便当的场景，还是那种角色能大显身手的场景？你会看那些并觉得，哦，这真是一场好戏吗？
Oh, I made it to page 39. Okay. I think I'll do it. Would it be like where the character was killed or would it also be like where the character can really score? Would you look at that and go like, oh, this is a good scene?
这，你知道我的意思吗？哦，好吧，是的。会有那种情况，就是，如果这是一个很好的戏剧角色，或者里面有一场很棒的戏，但——是的，主要还是要么我挨揍，要么我拿着刀去追杀某人，然后最终领便当，而且——是的，有那么一段时间情况就是这样。你和——我们刚刚聊到了，杰森你也刚刚说过，你演了那么多不同的——不仅仅是那么多不同的角色，还有那么多
This is, you know what I mean? Oh, well, yeah. It was a, yeah. I mean, there's that stuff where, like, if it's a good dramatic part or there was like a good scene but but yeah mainly i would either get i would either get beat up or i would be chasing somebody with a knife or and then eventually get get killed and um yeah it went that way for a while you and and sir we touched on it and jason you just said too you did so many different not just so many different characters but so many
不同类型、不同规模的电影。你演过这些好莱坞超级大制作，也演过这些非常迷你的独立片。事实上，你和我们的共同朋友汤姆·迪奇洛一起拍了具有开创意义的独立电影《开拍之前》，讲的就是拍独立电影的事，那也是我的最爱之一。然后你刚才说你喜欢跟年轻的有潜力的导演合作。
different kinds of you know a size of films you've done these huge Hollywood films, and you've done these really small. In fact, you made the seminal independent film Living in Oblivion with our mutual friend, Tom DeChillo, which is about making an independent film, which is one of my favorites. And then you just said that you like working with young up-and-coming directors.
是因为你喜欢那种融入某种氛围的感觉吗？去感受一个刚刚找到方向并进行探索的人？这会让你感到兴奋吗？是这样的吗？是的，是的。我太喜欢了，你知道的，而且我超级庆幸自己能成为昆汀第一部电影的一部分，你知道的，他——那对我们所有人来说都非常令人兴奋，看到像他这样的人
Is it that you like the feeling of being part of that vibe of somebody who's just finding their way and exploring? Is that exciting to you? Is that what it is? Yeah, yeah. love that you know um and i'm so like happy that i was you know part of quentin's first film you know like he you know that was i think really exciting for all of us uh to see somebody like him
而且他对自己在做的事情有着十足的自信，我认为正是这一点把我们所有人都震撼到了，他有着如此清晰的观点，所以那种能量是具有感染力的，你知道的。这会让你对身处这个行业感到心情舒畅，是的。是的，你知道的，虽然不是很了解你，史蒂夫，但我从你身上能感觉到——如果你觉得我说得不对请纠正我——你充满了感激和感恩，感谢自己作为一名演员在生活中处于现在的位置。我觉得我绝对想象不出你在任何片场会成为一个问题人物，或者闹出什么乱子。因为某些，你知道的，演员有很多很多类型，
um and he had such confidence in what he was doing that that's what i think blew all of us away that he um it was such a clear point of you so that that kind of energy is is contagious you know It just makes you feel good about being in this business, yeah. Yeah, you know, and not knowing you very well, Steve, is like, I get a sense from you that you're, and you correct me if I'm wrong, you're filled with gratitude and appreciation for working in where you are in life as an actor. Like, I can't ever see you being a problem on any set ever, or having an issue. Like, there's certain, you know, there's many, many types of actors,
其中很多人迫不及待地想分享他们所有的想法和背景，然后来到片场，你知道，有那种类型的演员，然后还有其他类型的演员，他们只是说，是的，我已经研究好我的角色了，我有几个想法，但你是老大——你属于哪一种？我想，是的，我觉得我属于……
and a lot of them can't wait to share all of their ideas and their back and come to set. you know there's those types and then there's other types that are just like yes I've studied my role I have a few ideas but you're in charge like where do you fall I think yeah I think I fall into
我是说，我跟如此之多的不同导演合作过，我喜欢观察他们的风格是什么，以及我该如何去配合。自从我自己也开始当导演之后，我就更是如此了，因为现在我亲身经历了导演们所经历的一切。
I mean I I've worked with so many different directors and I like to see what their style is and how I can be accommodating and since I've been directing I'm even more so because now I know what directors go through
很多时候，他们只是在极力保证拍摄进度，对吧？就像——你可不想成为那种……是的，我们经常和杰森聊起这个，因为我老是问杰森关于身处任何一边（演员或导演）的不同之处。所以，你现在也有这种体会了。对啊，我是说，你知道的，就像，我为什么要从这扇门进来？难道你不觉得我应该——这就像不是，好吧，你希望我从哪儿进来？好吧，很好。
A lot of the times they're just trying to make the day, right? Just like, and you don't want to be like... Yeah, we talk with Jason about it all the time because I always ask Jason about the difference between being on either side. So, and you have that too now. Yeah, I mean, you know, it's like, well, why would I come through this door? Like, don't you think I should, it's like not, okay, where do you want me to come through? Okay, good.
就像，我自己能琢磨出我的动机，如果你希望我这么做的话。只有当某些事情真的感觉不对劲时——如果我无法从有机层面找到自己为什么要这么做、或者如果走位感觉不对劲，那我才会开口说出来，但总的来说，是的，我只是喜欢出现在片场，然后把事情做好，对吧？作为导演，你作为导演时有没有遇到过那种时刻，你不得不说：他妈的直接从门里走进来就行了，老兄！是的，对吧？为什么非要走这扇门？因为这是我们仅有的一扇门！而且你需要进入这场戏里，所以我们需要你进来演这场戏。没错，就是这样。你有过那种时刻吗？我真的想不起来有谁会那样对我，而且，你知道的，我——
Like, I could figure out my own motivation, like, if you want me to do this. And it's only when something really doesn't feel. feel right like if I can't find my way around like organically why I'm doing something or if the blocking feels off yeah then I'll say something but but generally yeah I just like to show up and and kind of do it yeah right as a director do you as a director have you had those moments where you've had to say just come through the fucking door man yeah right why the door because it's the only door that we have right and you need to come into the scene so we need you in here to do the scene. Right, that's right. Have you had those moments? I really can't think of anybody who was like that way with me and, you know, I've, I mean,
我确实有过那种时刻，但作为一名演员，我总是喜欢看演员能想出什么点子，你知道的。如果我有时间去适当地排练某场戏——虽然你并不总是有这种奢侈，我喜欢看演员自然而然地表现，然后再试着，你知道的，然后确定场景的走位。有时你并没有那种奢侈，你知道的。你只想直接切入正题，说：好吧，演员们还没到，让我们看看能不能让他们在这个位置、这个位置，然后我们就可以拍了。没错，所以你会想：我们都已经为这个布景准备好了。
I've had moments, but I, and, you know, being an actor, I always like to see what the actor will come up with, you know. If I have time to, like, rehearse something properly, which you don't always, I like to see what the actors do naturally and then try and, you know, and then block the scene. Sometimes you don't have that luxury, you know. You just want to get in there and say, okay, the actors aren't here yet. Let's see if we can get them to be, you know, this one here, this one here, and then we can shoot it. Right, so you're like, we're already set up for this.
所以事情就会这样进行。不过，J.B.，你有没有过那种时候，你不得不直接说：他妈的，照做就行了，是的？我是说，有过上千次，因为我——因为我，我个人非常坚信摄像机能够帮助观众理解这场戏讲的是什么。所以很多时候，我会提前制定好一个庞大的计划，搞清楚镜头调度会是怎么样的，这意味着演员必须站在特定的位置。所以我回尽量鼓励演员去适应这种走位，但如果他们实在不习惯，我当然也可以灵活变通。不过，史蒂夫，凭借你所有那些不可思议的片场经验，以及你合作过的那么多出色的导演，
So this is how it's going to go. But, J.B., have you ever had that where you've had to kind of like just go, fucking just to do it, yeah. I mean, a thousand times because I, I, I, yeah, because I, I, personally, I'm such a fan of what the camera can do to help the audience understand what the scene is about. So oftentimes I'll have a huge. plan already worked out about what the coverage is going to be and that's that means that people have to be in certain spots and so i'll try to encourage the actors to make a friend of that blocking but if they if they don't if they aren't comfortable with it i can pivot for sure but uh steve uh with all the the the incredible set experience that you have and and the number of fantastic directors that you've
听到你说你有时会被新导演吸引，这让我觉得很有意思。因为在你身上，你似乎经常会遇到这种情况：那个导演可能会被每天拍摄中突如其来的各种复杂状况搞得焦头烂额，而你可能会感到沮丧，比如，天哪，这——你知道的，对于一个经历过那么多运作良好的片场的人来说，去施展你的耐心和经验来帮助一个年轻导演，这多少会让你觉得沮丧。我发现你真的太慷慨了。这会让人感到精疲力竭吗？但我其实并没有感受到那种有时确实会针对某个具体导演而产生的挫败感。我有时——这些年来我经历过太多片场了，我感到沮丧的可能是……
worked with. It's interesting to me to hear you say that you are that you gravitate towards new directors at times because it seems like you would you'd often be in a situation where you know, that director might be drowning in the the unforeseen complications of any day and you might get frustrated with like, oh my God, this is, you know, it's frustrating for you to have been on so many sets that work so well to then be sort of extending your patience and your experience to help out a young director. I find that just so generous of you. And is it taxing? But I don't really find the frustration that I do sometimes feel with the person who is directing. I sometimes, I've just been on so many sets over the years. I get frustrated with maybe like,
合作过的。听到你说有时候你会倾向于新导演，我觉得挺有意思的，因为我觉得你经常会遇到这样一种情况：你知道，那个导演可能会被每天意料之外的复杂情况弄得不知所措，你可能会觉得沮丧，比如说，天哪，你知道的，你经历过那么多运作得很好的片场，现在却要展现出你的耐心和经验来帮助一个年轻导演，这让你觉得很沮丧。我觉得你真的太慷慨了。这很累人吗？但我确实没有感到那种有时对导演本人感到的沮丧。有时候，这些年来我待过太多片场了。我可能会对……感到沮丧
why did they bring me in this early? Or why are they shooting this first? It's the first A.D. you're yelling at. Why are they, you know? And so, and especially on, you know, boardwalk empire was the first time I had played a character like, you know, repeatedly. And for however many seasons that we did, five,
为什么他们让我来得这么早？或者为什么他们先拍这场戏？你要对第一副导演发火。为什么他们，你知道的？所以，特别是在，你知道的，《大西洋帝国》是我第一次连续扮演一个这样的角色，你知道的。而且不管我们拍了多少季，拍了五季，
and towards the end, I think I did start to, you know, be the guy that wouldn't, you know, like they'd call me to set. And I would just go, all right, I'm just going to sit here for another 10 minutes until they really need me. But then that kind of like... Yeah. Then they're like, well, he's not coming out. So now they would call me even earlier.
到了后期，我想我确实开始，你知道的，成为那种不会，你知道的，比如他们叫我去片场。然后我就会想，好吧，我还是在这里再坐十分钟，直到他们真正需要我。但后来那种……对。然后他们就会想，好吧，他没出来。所以现在他们会叫得更早。
You know, like the next time. It just, yeah, it just... Yeah. But I love doing that show, yeah. Well, that must... Then you must really... You must love... Well, you tell me, do you love directing?
你知道的，就像下一次一样。这，对，这只是……对。但我很喜欢拍那部剧，对。好吧，那一定……那你一定真的很……你一定很喜欢……好吧，你告诉我，你喜欢当导演吗？
I'll bet you do. In theory. It makes me the most anxious... Like, when I direct, I get so anxious that it's... I'm beside myself. And I don't do it or not. I just feel like I'm, you know, I'm insecure.
我敢说你喜欢。理论上是。这让我最焦虑……比如，当我执导时，我焦虑得无以复加……我简直不知所措。我不知道该不该拍。我只是觉得自己，你知道的，我很没有安全感。
I'm not really, I don't really know what I'm doing. I don't know about camera stuff. See, that's my weakness is that I'll come on set and I'll say, you know what I'm, and I'll say the DP, I'm thinking, how about if we do this and the DP will say, oh, well, you know, the light's coming in this way and this is, and I would go, oh, yeah, right, right. Right, okay, yeah, yeah, you're right. And now I just go talk to the actor, look to the DP and go, what do we do? Like, what do we do? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. And I find eight out of ten directors work like that.
我其实，我真的不知道自己在做什么。我对摄影方面的东西一窍不通。你看，这就是我的弱点，我来到片场会说，你知道我在，我会对摄影指导说，我在想，如果我们这样做怎么样，然后摄影指导会说，哦，好吧，你知道的，光是从这边过来，这是，然后我会说，哦，对，没错，没错。对，好吧，对，对，你是对的。现在我只会去找演员谈戏，然后看着摄影指导说，我们该怎么做？就像，我们该怎么做？对，对，对，对。我发现十分之八的导演都是这样工作的。
Don't you find that? A lot of directors would just sort of punt all the camera stuff to the DP and the operator, and then they go and they work with the actors, which is a great way to do it as well. There's so many different ways to do it. Yeah, there are, but I get so jealous of directors when they say to the DP, so what do you think, a 40? You didn't think of 35? And I'm like, what are they talking?
你不觉得吗？很多导演只是把所有摄影方面的事情都推给摄影指导和摄像师，然后他们去和演员合作，这也是一种很棒的方法。有太多不同的方法了。对，确实有，但我太嫉妒那些导演了，当他们对摄影指导说，那你觉得呢，用40毫米镜头？你没想过35毫米吗？我就想，他们在说什么？
Like, why don't I know this? Whatever you're doing, you're doing it just right. Yeah, you're keep going. Of all the genres you've done, is there any genre, well, is there a genre that you haven't done that you want to do or is there a genre that you have done and that you will never do again? Yeah, yeah.
就像，为什么我不知道这个？不管你在做什么，你做得很对。对，你继续。在你拍过的所有类型片中，有没有哪种类型片，呃，有没有哪种你还没拍过但想拍的类型片，或者有没有哪种你拍过但再也不想拍了？对，对。
I mean, I really haven't done horror. I've done, like, a little bit. There's some TV shows back. in the day like Tales from the Crypt and there was a show called monsters and um but i've never done like a horror movie and but i don't know if i could i don't i i'm pretty squeamish and i don't like prosthetic makeup like i've done that in the past like um and like sitting in the chair for five hours sitting in the chair yeah yeah but your your your ability to uh to ground violence is awesome i just love watching you uh deal with with the um the unsettling unpredictability of
我的意思是，我真的没拍过恐怖片。我拍过，就像，一点点。以前有一些电视剧，像《魔界奇谭》，还有一个叫《怪兽》的节目，嗯，但我从来没拍过恐怖片，而且我不知道我能不能行，我，我很胆小，我不喜欢假体化妆——比如我过去拍戏时化过，比如，嗯，在椅子上坐五个小时，坐在椅子上，对，对。不过你，你将暴力落地的能力太棒了，我就是喜欢看你，呃，处理那种……不安的、不可预测的
violence coming on someone that is just normal uh there's a bit eccentric but like living in our world like you you just ground violence very well to a point where oh my god that that's really shocking because it seems like it's really happening to someone in our real world. I mean, I, you know, Fargo's top three films I've ever seen in my life. I've seen it more than any other film. It's so good.
暴力降临到一个正常人身上，有一点古怪，但就像生活在我们的世界里——就像你，你把暴力表现得很接地气，以至于，天哪，这真的太令人震惊了，因为这看起来就像真的发生在现实世界中的某个人身上一样。我的意思是，我，你知道的，《冰血暴》是我一生中看过最好的三部电影之一。我看的次数比其他任何电影都多。它太棒了。
And just, just your way, just, not only just the, the violence that you're, that you deal with in that film, but even just your, your line of work in that film too, you know, that there's a, there's a grounded sense of, here's a guy who's, you know, dealing with, you know, the underbelly of society, but he's not super comfortable with it, but
而且，只是你处理这部电影中暴力的那种方式，不仅仅是暴力，甚至只是你在那部电影里的台词和职业，你知道的，有一种脚踏实地的感觉，这里有一个人，你知道的，在跟社会阴暗面打交道，但他并不是特别习惯，但是
you know, he's just, he's got to make a living and here we go. It's kind of matter of fact almost. It's so exciting to follow somebody like you through an eccentric storyline, because you just ground it all. You know who we are. I love that.
你知道的，他只是为了谋生，就这样吧。这几乎是理所当然的。跟着像你这样的人经历一个古怪的故事真的很让人兴奋，因为你把这一切都表现得很真实。你知道我们是谁。我太喜欢了。
Well, thank you. And that film was yeah, that was another seminal one for me because I had, you know, worked with the Cohen Brothers, a few times before that, but then in that film, they really gave me a part that was throughout the film, and I loved it. And I loved that character, you know, kind of, yeah, you know, thinking he's, you know, smarter than he really is, but, you know, but he had a certain kind of confidence, you know, that you're funny, you know. Well, especially as the way you interrelate with your, with your,
谢谢。那部电影，是的，那对我来说是另一部具有开创性的作品，因为我在那之前已经和科恩兄弟合作过几次了，但在那部电影里，他们真的给了我一个贯穿全片的角色，我太喜欢了。我喜欢那个角色，你知道的，有点，嗯，觉得自己比实际上更聪明，但是，你知道的，但他有一种特定的自信，你知道的，你很搞笑，你知道的。特别是你和你那个，
your cohort there, Peter Stromar, yeah. Stromar, yeah. I just love that sort of, uh, I just love that sort of alpha-beta thing you guys had going where you're just you're the smartest guy in the world when it's just the two of you guys you know and then you get thrown out amongst the other characters and you're in trouble I just yeah you with a bloody face
你的搭档彼得·斯特曼的互动方式，对。斯特曼，对。我太喜欢那种，呃，我太喜欢你们之间那种阿尔法与贝塔的关系了，当只有你们两个人的时候，你就是世界上最聪明的人，你知道的，然后你被扔进其他角色中间，你就陷入麻烦了。我只是，对，你带着一张流血的脸，
getting angry at everybody around you just made me pee in my pants how many how many films did you do with the Cohen brother because you I mean yeah you mentioned it you've worked with them before you worked with them you did Big Lobowski was after that was after Fargo yeah yeah which is weird I always think of it as being before
对周围每个人发火的样子，简直让我笑得尿裤子。你跟科恩兄弟合作了多少部电影？因为你——我的意思是，对，你提到了，你以前和他们合作过，你合作过，你演《谋杀绿脚趾》是在那之后——那是在《冰血暴》之后，对，对。这很奇怪，我一直以为是在那之前。
No, that was their follow-up to Fargo, which was kind of amazing because they had finally, like, broken into the mainstream because Fargo was nominated, right? Right, right. So now, like, everybody was seeing this film and we're starting to really, you know, get to know the Coen brothers in a mainstream way. And then they follow up with this film that I remember when it came out. People really didn't know what to make of it. It took a good five years for people to, like, catch on. Could it have a bigger cult following? I don't know if a film could have a bigger cult following than Big Lobowski.
不，那是他们继《冰血暴》之后的又一部作品，这简直太神奇了，因为他们终于打入了主流市场，因为《冰血暴》获得了提名，对吧？对，对。所以现在，每个人都在看这部电影，我们开始真正地，你知道的，以主流的方式了解科恩兄弟。然后他们推出了这部电影，我记得它上映时，人们真的不知道该怎么看待它。花了整整五年时间，人们才开始领会。可能有一部更大的邪典电影吗？我不知道是否有一部电影能比《谋杀绿脚趾》拥有更大的邪典追捧。
Yeah. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show. And now, actors are lucky enough if you're in one-hit anything. One-hit play, TV, show. And you've had all of these things that you've been a part of that are, like, hit after hit after hit like it's kind of extraordinary do you are you able to allow yourself to appreciate that and and be like i'm kind of proud of like i'm proud of what i've done i mean of course
我们马上回来。现在，回到节目中。现在，演员们如果能参演任何一部大热作品，就已经足够幸运了。热门戏剧、电视剧、节目。而你参演的所有这些作品，都是一部接一部又一部的热门，这简直太不可思议了，你能够让自己去欣赏这一点，并且觉得——我为我做过的事感到骄傲吗？我的意思是，当然，
you are you don't have to say it out loud but but or are you one of the people that kind of deflect say it out loud i mean or can you absorb that because it's very rare for somebody to be in that many hit hit things yeah i mean i'm very proud of it and i feel very grateful for it and at the same time I feel like I haven't been in you know like I've I've never done like a Marvel movie I've never done like I haven't done you know I'm popcorn things yeah yeah I mean I did you know like I like Armageddon and Con Air were my two like like big movies that I did in the 90s but I really haven't done stuff like that so much since yeah but I'm I don't care I mean I'm very happy with yeah that's kind of what I'm saying yeah you lend you lend you lend so
你不用大声说出来，但是，或者你是那种会回避的人？大声说出来，我的意思是，或者你能接受这一点，因为一个人能参演那么多热门作品是非常罕见的。对，我的意思是，我为此感到非常骄傲，我对此心存感激，与此同时，我觉得我没有参演过，你知道的，就像我从未拍过漫威电影，我从没拍过爆米花电影，对，对。我的意思是，我拍过，你知道的，我喜欢《绝世天劫》和《空中监狱》，这是我在90年代拍的两部大制作电影，但自那以后我真的没怎么拍过那种类型的电影了，不过我不在乎，我的意思是，我对……我很满意。对，这正是我要说的。对，你为那些电影增添了
much credibility and artistic rigor to those films like that was a that was a very nice thing you did for those couple of films um and i'll bet you could do that a ton more if you wanted to um i bet marvel would have you in a second um yeah yeah but you are you're just such actor and director you know catnip uh yeah i i i hope you're as proud as you deserve to be about you know the the position that you hold in this community is so well earned Steve well thank you coming from you and all you guys
如此多的信誉和艺术严谨性——你为那几部电影做了一件非常棒的事，嗯，我敢打赌，如果你愿意，你可以做得更多，嗯，我敢打赌漫威会立刻邀请你，嗯，对，对，但你简直就是演员和导演的催化剂，对，我希望你为自己在影视圈所处的地位感到由衷的骄傲，这是你应得的，史蒂夫。谢谢，从你和你们所有人嘴里说出来，
it just means so much to me because I really you've got some pretty memorable deaths on screen yeah that's true do you have a favorite is there a favorite Steve Bouchard matter of dying? I do think my
对我来说意义重大，因为我真的——你在银幕上有过几个非常令人难忘的死法，对，那是真的，你有最喜欢的吗？史蒂夫·布西密之死，有没有最喜欢的？我确实认为我
favorite was in the Big Lobowski just literally being scared to death yeah it made no sense like when i read the script i was like i think i'm going to make it through this one i think you know and it's like what he's he's dead you know yeah um you also that's so good have you also mentioned um that you improvised in that in that in that audition that quentin saw you in
最喜欢的死法是在《谋杀绿脚趾》里，字面意义上的吓死，对，这毫无逻辑，当我读剧本时，我想，我觉得我能挺过这一关，我想，你知道的，结果却是——什么？他死了，你知道的，对，嗯。你还——太棒了。你还提到过，你在那次昆汀看见你的试镜里即兴发挥了，
in i'm sure you've improvised a lot of movies and i know you know we you've had the opportunity of working with so many great writers who've written and you've mentioned so many great pieces of material but has there ever been an improvised line I've always wanted to know like is there something in a movie somewhere that you're like
在——我确信你即兴演过很多电影，我知道你，你知道的，你有机会与那么多伟大的编剧合作，他们写过剧本，你也提到了那么多优秀的剧本素材，但有没有哪一句即兴台词是我一直想知道的——比如电影里有没有什么地方让你感到
proud of that you that you improvised and that made it in the movie and you're like oh yeah yeah well actually in Armageddon I mean Michael Bay let us you know
骄傲，是你即兴发挥并最终剪进电影里的，然后你会想，哦，对，对？实际上，在《绝世天劫》里，迈克尔·贝让我们，你知道的，
improvise a lot you know like you know I mean we would we would do the scene but then um the one thing I remember when I was sitting on
即兴发挥了很多，你知道的，我的意思是，我们会先把戏演完，然后，嗯，我记得我坐在
the nuclear weapon and I just and I said so I was like no nukes no nukes that was just from me and it made it into the movie God that movie was so huge that it was such a massive hit
核武器上时，我随口说了一句：没有核武器，没有核武器！那是我的即兴发挥，最后被剪进了电影里。天哪，那部电影太火了，简直是一个超级大热门。
yeah oh my God so Steve what it with again with all of the stuff that you've done and all the directors that you've worked with and the parts that you've played aside from Marvel is there something that you that you hope to
对，天哪。所以史蒂夫，结合你所做的一切、你合作过的所有导演以及你扮演过的角色，除了漫威之外，你有什么希望
to do sometime soon and that can be as an actor or as a director you know are you looking to maybe direct one of those
不久的将来能做的事吗？作为演员还是导演？你知道的，你有没有想过去执导其中一部
one of those big sort of popcorn big pieces of business things or or act in one of those you know I've never really had a plan for you know and and I've been you know I mean we all get to ask
那种宏大的商业爆米花大制作，或者在其中演个角色？你知道的，我从来没有为未来做过什么计划，而且我也一直，你知道的，我的意思是，我们都会被问到
like what's your dream role and or if you know Or to work with somebody, a director. Or to work with somebody, and I get superstitious about, well, I've never worked with so-and-so, and I feel like if I say it out loud, you know. Although, sometimes you say it out loud and it happened. That's true. Because they get to hear it.
比如你梦想中的角色是什么？或者，你知道的，想和哪个导演合作。或者想和谁合作，我对这些事情有点迷信，比如，我从来没和某某合作过，我觉得如果我大声说出来，你知道的。不过，有时候你大声说出来，它真的发生了。确实如此。因为他们听到了。
What about theater? Have you, I apologize for not knowing, but if you don't take Sean, and apologize for taking Sean's question, but go ahead, Jason. Sean will have the follow-up about anything funny that happened on stage. But do you enjoy doing that, or does it take too much? time off of your availability yeah you know i mean i used to do in the 80s when i lived in these village which was like an amazing place and time to live i had a um a partner mark boone junior who you guys may know um he was uh he's you know he's done a lot of great work he was and
那戏剧呢？你，很抱歉我不知道，如果你不介意肖恩，抱歉抢了肖恩的问题，但请继续，杰森。肖恩会有后续问题，关于舞台上发生的任何趣事。但你喜欢演话剧吗？还是说这占用了你太多时间？
a lot of people know him from sons of anarchy he played the character of bobby oh yeah yeah i know mark did you didn't you work with boon yeah i did i did i did work with boon yeah i did i did Yeah. Yeah, he did Flaket. He did our show Flakeet. Yes, yes, yes. He's terrific. God, what a great actor.
对，你知道的，我的意思是，80年代我住在格林威治村时经常演，那是一个生活和工作都非常棒的地方和时期，我有一个，嗯，搭档马克·布恩·儒尼奥尔，你们可能认识，嗯，他是个，你知道的，他做过很多伟大的工作，他曾是，
We used to write and perform our own, like, short sketches and some plays. And that was, you know, I think I never felt more creative as when I was doing that, you know, working with him. And then working with other, I worked a little bit with the Worcester Group, another, another playwright director, on Jezarin and I did a lot of that stuff then and then when I sort of transitioned into film I just felt like I was spoiled by like
很多人通过《混乱之子》认识他，他演了鲍比这个角色。哦，对，对，我认识马克。你不是和布恩合作过吗？对，我合作过，我确实和布恩合作过，对，我合作过。对。对，他演过《Flaket》。他演过我们的剧《Flaket》。是的，是的，是的。他太棒了。天哪，真是个伟大的演员。
all the great people and fun that I had doing that in the 80s it was hard for me to make a transition and say like they want me to do what how many how many shows a week? I think the eight shows a week thing is like the dumbest thing in the world yeah it's brutal
我们过去常常自己写和表演一些短剧和话剧。那是，你知道的，我想我从来没有像当时那样感到如此富有创造力，你知道的，和他一起工作。然后和其他人合作，我跟伍斯特剧团合作过一点，那是另一个，另一个编剧兼导演，演过《Jezarin》，我当时做了很多那种事情，后来当我转型拍电影时，我只是觉得自己被宠坏了，因为
and then I was just yeah I guess I just sort of kept myself open, you know, for like film and TV stuff. The last play that I did was over 20 years ago, but it was amazing. It was Simon McBurney directed it, and it was
80年代做那些事时遇到所有那些伟大的人和获得的乐趣，让我很难完成转型，去想：他们让我做什么？一周演几场？我觉得一周八场戏这种事简直是世上最蠢的事，对，太残酷了。
Arturo Owee and Al Pacino played Arturo Owee. They had an amazing cast, and it was a, yeah, it was a star-studied cast. And you were supposed to do something with Oscar Isaac, right, around the pandemic? We were going to do, yeah, we were going to do, I
然后我就，对，我想我只是让自己保持开放的心态，你知道的，去接电影和电视方面的工作。我演的最后一部话剧是20多年前了，但它太棒了。西蒙·麦克伯尼导演的，那是
It was three sisters, yeah. Oh, three sisters, right, right. And the pandemic... That was going to be the original title of our podcast. Yeah. It was taken. It was taken. The pandemic, put that on hold, and then it just kind of fell apart.
《阿图罗·乌伊的发迹》，阿尔·帕西诺饰演阿图罗·乌伊。他们有一支出色的演员阵容，那是一部，对，星光熠熠的阵容。你本来要和奥斯卡·伊萨克合作点什么的，对吧，在疫情前后？我们本来打算，对，我们打算，我
I've tried to do some things over the years, but it just never worked out. So we mentioned that, you know, how much you work, and again, like, how many roles you've done it, and it's, you know, obviously, you're busy a lot. where you just you work a lot you must I don't know if it feels like you work a lot but you do yeah no it does yeah so what what is what do you do are you East Coast base or you West Coast base most of the time I'm East Coast yeah East Coast yeah East Coast New York yeah and then what's a what's a day what's if you're not on set you're not working on something what's an average day for Steve Bouchemy you wake up and you have a you're a coffee tea matcha what are you definitely coffee, black coffee in the morning and just read like, you know, the times or whatever news feed is on my phone and do that and then...
那是《三姐妹》，对。哦，《三姐妹》，对，对。而疫情……那是我们播客最初的起名。对。已经被用了。被用了。疫情把这事搁置了，然后它就泡汤了。
I don't do, you know, like I do yoga. We do yoga on the weekends. Nice. For a little while I was working out, but I'm not, yeah, I... But are you walking around? Are you going to lunch? You're going to read books? You're going to museums? Are you watching reality TV?
这些年来我尝试过做一些事情，但总是没能成功。所以我们提到了，你知道的，你工作有多拼，再次强调，你演了多少角色，而且，你知道的，显然你一直很忙，你就是工作很多，你一定——我不知道这感觉是不是像你工作很多，但你确实如此。不，确实是，对。所以你平时都做些什么？你是东海岸基地还是西海岸基地？我大部分时间在东海岸，对，东海岸，纽约，对。然后，普通的一天是怎样的？如果你不在片场，没有在拍戏，史蒂夫·布西密的平常一天是怎样的？你醒来后喝咖啡、茶还是抹茶？你绝对是咖啡，早上喝黑咖啡，然后读读，你知道的，《泰晤士报》或者手机上的任何新闻资讯，然后……
No, I don't watch reality TV. I mean, I catch up on shows and movies and I like doing that, and I like hanging out with friends and visiting my mom, who's 92 now, and she lives now like a block away from me. But it's a pretty sort of, you know, uneventful life that I lead. Sounds pretty good.
我不怎么做，你知道的，我练瑜伽。我们周末做瑜伽。不错。有一段时间我在健身，但我没有，对，我……但你平时会散步吗？去吃午饭？看书？去博物馆？看真人秀电视节目吗？
No, but that sounds like a power down. Like you need to have kind of like quiet time where you kind of do nothing a little bit. What's your drink of choice? my wine yeah oh wine red white rose red wine red wine red wine red wine there you go all right yes it's pretty classic it's good to know hey well i have to ask you this yeah please do you remember when we were both nominated for uh 30 rock yeah yeah do you remember we were sitting next to each other at the emmys that happened like before the creative emmy yeah the creative emys because we were both
不，我不看真人秀。我的意思是，我会补看一些节目和电影，我很喜欢这样做，我喜欢和朋友闲逛，去看望我妈妈，她今年92岁了，她现在就住在离我一个街区的地方。但这是一种相当，你知道的，平淡无奇的生活。听起来挺不错的。
nominated for 30 Rock. And we were sitting next to each other, and so was Tim Conway. Oh, wow. Wait a second. Do you remember this? And we didn't say a word to each other. I think we were both kind of like nervous to talk to each other.
不，但这听起来像是在充电。就像你需要有那种安静的时光，什么都不做一会儿。你首选的饮品是什么？我的酒，对，哦，酒，红葡萄酒、白葡萄酒、桃红葡萄酒。红葡萄酒，红葡萄酒，红葡萄酒，红葡萄酒。给你，太经典了，很高兴知道。嘿，我得问你这个，对，请问。你还记得我们俩同时因《我为喜剧狂》被提名吗？
I was nervous to talk to you. Well, I was nervous to talk to you, and I had just, I had, right before that, I had introduced myself to Betty White, who was there. And as I was walking away from her, I heard her say to a friend, who was that? Then I was like, all right, I'm not going to say. say hi to anybody. And we sat there. And so when they got to our category,
对，对，你还记得我们在艾美奖上坐在一起吗？那是发生在创意艾美奖之前，对，创意艾美奖，因为我们俩都
it's Tim Conway. I mean, we're up, you know, I think we both knew. Before they announced his name, he ran up on stage. Which I thought was such a brilliant move. Because win or lose, it was great. It was so, you know. He did that. You know, it's funny.
因《我为喜剧狂》获得提名。我们坐在一起，蒂姆·康威也一样。哦，哇。等一下。你还记得这件事吗？我们俩一句话都没说。我想我们俩当时都挺紧张，不敢跟对方说话。
Steve, I do remember that. That's so crazy. I totally blanked on that. Did he end up winning? He did win. He did win. Of course you. He did win.
我当时挺紧张不敢跟你说话。好吧，我当时挺紧张不敢跟你说话，而且我刚刚，就在那之前，我向贝蒂·怀特做了自我介绍，她也在那儿。当我从她身边走开时，我听到她对一个朋友说：“那是谁？”然后我就想，好吧，我再也不跟任何人打招呼了。我们就坐在那儿。所以当轮到我们的奖项类别时，
But what he had done was, if you remember, in the 70s, he originated that bit that they kind of, they tried to copy years later for actress in a comedy. He originated the bit in 1975. I know it was that year because his year Chevy Chase was nominated for S&L. So it was like 75, 76. And they started listing off the nominees. And they go, Best Supporting After an Academy. Tim Connolly, and he walked up. And then each nominee walked up as if they had won.
那是蒂姆·康威。我的意思是，我们入围了，你知道的，我想我们俩都知道。在他们宣布他的名字之前，他一路小跑上了舞台。我觉得这真是个绝妙的举动。因为无论赢或输，这都很棒。太，你知道的。他做了那个。你知道，这很有趣。
That's really good. Just when they do the list of nominees and then they stood there and then Chevy Chase ended up winning. But they were all standing on stage. So I love that he years later extended that bit. And of course I remember that. It was so fucking crazy. And then when he took us, like he kind of like bowed and then pretended that he stabbed himself with the award and like kind of walked off holding his heart. I mean, was there anybody funnier than Tim Kahn?
史蒂夫，我真的记得。太疯狂了。我当时脑子完全一片空白。他最后得奖了吗？他确实得奖了。他得奖了。你当然知道。他确实得奖了。
No, I know. It was just, yeah, I was so excited to meet him. He, he one time, I saw a bit one time where he and Harvey Querman, Harvey Corman gets announced, he either won or was announced to come to the stage. And Tim Conn, he was wearing tails. And Tim Conway went and jumped on his tails and literally rode his coattails down the aisle. It was just working on so many different levels. Oh, God.
但他做过的是，如果你还记得的话，在70年代，他原创了那个段子，几年后他们试图在喜剧类女演员奖上模仿那个段子。他在1975年原创了那个段子。我知道是那一年，因为那一年切维·切斯因《周六夜现场》获得提名。所以大约是75、76年。他们开始宣读提名名单。他们说：“喜剧类最佳男配角，蒂姆·康威。”然后他走了上去。然后每个提名者都像自己获奖一样走了上去。
Love it. 30 Rock. 30 Rock. I know, I missed that show. Yeah, that was so much fun to work on. So your new show is coming out next. Well, whatever it is. I should know this.
这真的很棒。就在他们念完提名名单后，他们就站在那里，结果切维·切斯最后获奖了。但他们都站在舞台上。所以我很喜欢他多年后延续了这个段子。当然我记得。简直太疯狂了。然后当他拿走我们——他鞠了个躬，然后假装用奖杯刺伤自己，捂着心口走开了。我的意思是，还有谁比蒂姆·康威更搞笑吗？
This is my obligation. August 6, August 6, which is my son's birthday. So now I really remember. It's one of my son's birthdays. And then so what do we got in store for the rest of the summer, Steve? What are we looking to? Well, right now I'm working with Adam Sandler. is producing a movie.
不，我懂。太棒了，我很高兴能见到他。他，有一次，我看到过一个段子，蒂姆·康威和哈维·柯曼，哈维·柯曼的名字被宣布了，他要么获奖了，要么被宣布上台。蒂姆·康威穿着燕尾服，然后蒂姆·康威跑过去跳到了他的燕尾服后摆上，字面意义上顺着他的衣尾滑到了走道上。这简直在各个层面都太绝了。哦，天哪。
He's producing two movies that his daughters are in. So Sonny is in one film that I'm doing called Don't Say Good Luck. And Sadie is doing a film called Roommates. And last night was the premiere for Happy Gilmore Two. Happy Gilmore, too. I'm in that as well. And that was so much fun seeing, you know, that film. And we watched it again.
太喜欢了。《我为喜剧狂》。《我为喜剧狂》。我知道，我很怀念那部剧。对，参演那部剧太有趣了。所以你的新剧接下来要上映了。好吧，无论是什么。我应该知道的。
Like I watched the first one in the afternoon yesterday, just so I would be up on all the references, and they did it. It was just so satisfying and so funny, yeah. I'm sure, and I think that people maybe, and you can testify to this, and we all can, there's almost not a nicer guy or better dude in the world than Adam Sandler.
这是我的义务。8月6日，8月6日，正是我儿子的生日。所以我现在真的记住了。这是我儿子的生日之一。那么，史蒂夫，我们剩下这个夏天还有什么精彩内容等着我们？我们期待着什么？嗯，我现在正和亚当·桑德勒合作。他正在监制一部电影。
See, I differ. You know, everybody, this monster, he, I just, you got everybody fooled. I mean, he is the nicest man. He's the sweetest guy. On top of being so funny and everything's so talented, he's such a good dude. You really are.
他正在监制两部电影，他的女儿们都在里面。索尼参演了我正在拍的一部电影，叫《别说祝你好运》。萨蒂参演了一部叫《室友》的电影。昨晚是《快乐吉尔莫2》的首映礼。快乐吉尔莫2。我也参演了。看那部电影真的太有趣了。我们又看了一遍。
And he's so smart. So smart. I've worked with him since Airheads, right? Like, that was the first thing that we did to him. Oh, my gosh, that's right. And then he, you know, he was talking to us on set about how he wanted to, like, do his own film. And Robert Simons, who was,
就像我昨天下午看了第一部一样，就是为了能跟上所有的梗，他们做到了。太令人满意了，太搞笑了，对。我确信，我想人们也许——你可以为此作证，我们都可以——世上几乎没有比亚当·桑德勒更好的人或更棒的家伙了。
one of the producers on Airheads, you know, took him up on it and produced Billy Madison. And Adam asked me to do like a small thing in that. And it was so much fun. But to watch Adam over the years, because his friends used to show up on set, you know, and just hang out. And then each movie I've done with them, I notice, oh, those friends are now in the movies. Those friends are his writers. Those friends are his producers. Yeah.
看，我有不同看法。你知道，每个人，这个怪物，他——我只是，你们都被他骗了。我的意思是，他是最nice的人。他是最温柔的家伙。除了搞笑和极具才华之外，他还是个如此优秀的人。你真的是。
And he's so, not only is he loyal to them, but that's what I mean by smart. He knows what brings out the best in him, and he knows that they will bring, you know, like gold. And so, and he makes movies that he wants to see. You know, I don't think Adam ever makes something that he's trying to, you know, find an audience for. It's stuff that he really, like, wants, that he wants to see, that he thinks is funny. Yeah, he really does. He champions people and also, like you. He's so diverse and can do, he has so many different gears.
而且他太聪明了。太聪明了。我从《头盔》开始就跟他合作了，对吧？那是我们合作的第一件事。哦，天哪，没错。然后他，你知道的，他在片场跟我们谈论他想如何拍摄自己的电影，而罗伯特·西蒙斯，他是
Oh, yeah. It's unbelievable. I was so happy for him that when he started doing dramatic roles, and I was so pissed off at myself that I hadn't, like, you know, like written something dramatic for him, you know, first, you know, because I could see it in him. And I used to tell him that. What was it first?
《头盔》的制片人之一，你知道的，采纳了他的建议，监制了《阿呆与阿瓜》。亚当邀请我在里面演一个小角色。太有趣了。但看着亚当这些年来的变化，因为他的朋友们过去经常出现在片场，你知道的，就在那儿闲逛。然后我跟他合作的每一部电影，我都注意到，哦，那些朋友现在都在电影里了。那些朋友是他的编剧。那些朋友是他的制片人。对。
He's an amazing musician. Yeah, Punch Drunk Club was the first one, I think, that really kind of, you know, where people started to see him. in a different light. And then, of course, I mean, uncut gems. I mean, come on. Yeah, forget it. Incredible.
而且他不仅对他们忠诚，这就是我所说的聪明。他知道是什么能激发出他最好的一面，他知道他们会带来，你知道的，比如黄金。所以，而且他只拍自己想看的电影。你知道的，我不认为亚当拍过任何迎合观众的电影。那是他真正喜欢、想看、并且觉得好笑的东西。对，他真的是这样。他支持其他人，而且就像你一样。他很多才多艺，能驾驭各种不同的风格。
Yeah. Yeah. Well, Steve, what an absolute delight. I'm sorry that we never, that you and I didn't speak to each other at the Emmys and all those. We did exchange a few words. We didn't really go deep, but we were both losers. We were just losers that night. And, uh, but it's what a thrill to have you, man.
哦，对。太不可思议了。我为他感到高兴，当他开始尝试正剧角色时，我对自己生闷气，因为我没有早点，你知道的，比如先为他写一部正剧剧本，你知道的，因为我从他身上看到了这种潜力。我过去经常这样告诉他。那是第一次吗？
It just honestly, just such an absolute thrill. I'm so excited to have met you, Steve. Thank you so much. This is such an honor for me to be with you guys. And Wednesday, Wednesday on Netflix, August 6th, we'll look forward to it season two of Wednesday. Steve, just sending you lots of love and all the best of luck and continued success.
他是个出色的音乐家。对，《狂野之爱》是第一部吧，我想，那部电影真正让人们开始以不同的眼光看待他。然后，当然，我的意思是《原钻》。我的意思是，拜托。对，别提了。太不可思议了。
You're just the greatest. Thank you. And sending love and all the success to you guys too. Thank you. I love what you do. So thank you. Thank you so much. Thank you.
对。好吧，史蒂夫，这真是一次绝对的享受。我很遗憾我们从未——你和我没有在艾美奖上交谈，以及所有那些。我们确实交换了几句话。我们没有深入交流，但我们俩都是失败者。那天晚上我们只是失败者。而且，呃，能邀请到你真是太荣幸了，老兄。
Enjoy the rest of your summer. Thank you. The great Steve Buscemi. Thank you, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. How about that guy? Talking about a guy who's done at all. Yeah. Yeah, that was, I'm still a little kind of in shock there.
说实话，这绝对是一个极大的荣幸。很高兴能认识你，史蒂夫。非常感谢。能和你们在一起对我来说真是个极大的荣誉。周三，Netflix上的周三，8月6日，我们拭目以待《星期娜》第二季。史蒂夫，向你致以满满的爱意，祝你一切顺利，并不断取得成功。
I know. That's a guy I'm just like such a enormous fan of his. And I just, for some reason, he just seems like a guy. I always thought I would never, ever be able to meet. You know, it's just like one of those guys that like zero circles I know or that I'm in. He just lives like in a cool zone. Yeah, he's not out there fucking cutting ribbons at markets and permits. and premieres and shit like that.
你简直太棒了。谢谢。也把爱和所有的成功送给你们。谢谢。我喜欢你们做的事。非常感谢。非常感谢。谢谢。
Like, he's just like... Cutting rare. If I got lucky enough to baby be in a project with him, but, you know, what are the odds? Wait, are you spending time with a lot of ribbon cutters? Oh, yeah. I bring my own scissors, you know, I don't... My germaphobe, so...
享受剩下的夏天吧。谢谢。伟大的史蒂夫·布西密。谢谢，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。觉得那家伙怎么样？说起一个什么都经历过的家伙。对。对，那，我还是有点震惊。
He is good, Willie, when you announced him on, when you were revealing, and Jason guessed it, I was like, right away, and I was like, oh, yeah. And he came on, it's one of those people, like Jay just saying, you're like, oh, my God, it would be so cool to hang out. with him and oh we're hanging out with them like i know i know i know i know it's just a thrill what a fucking talent and talk about yeah what he lends each project and you know he's in the cast list i agree oh okay so they're not fucking around on this film raises all boats right i didn't yeah and i didn't know he
我知道。那是一个我极其崇拜的家伙。不知为什么，他就像那种人。我一直以为我永远、永远不可能见到他。你知道的，就好像他属于那种我认识的零交集或我不在的圈子。他生活在一个酷炫的领域。对，他才不会去市场上剪彩剪红带、去首映礼这些破事呢。
did stand up like you know like i you should have some of your stand up oh i have some oh do you oh oh oh yeah oh oh yeah oh yeah you want anything you're workshopping yeah do i what did this what did the sushi say to the bee. Huh. Give me a second here. Oh, Shane. Wasabi. That you really got cheap.
就像，他只是——剪彩。如果我足够幸运能和他一起参与一个项目，但是，你知道的，几率有多大？等等，你花很多时间跟剪彩的人在一起吗？哦，对。我自己带剪刀，你知道，我不会……我有洁癖，所以……
Oh, because, you know, there's a lot in there that is close to my heart. You know? Right. The mock, bro talk. Right. And the pun. And the underused sushi mustard, you know. Right.
他确实很棒，威利，当你宣布他出场时，当你在揭晓而杰森猜中时，我立刻就想到了，我就想，哦，对。当他出场时，就像杰森刚才说的，你会想，哦，天哪，能和他一起闲逛会多酷啊。跟他一起闲逛——我知道，我知道，我知道，这简直是一种刺激，真是个该死的奇才！说到他为每个项目贡献了什么，你知道他在演员表里——我同意，哦，好吧，所以他们在这部电影里可没开玩笑，这让所有人水涨船高，对吧？我没——对，我不知道他
I just don't think gets a fair shake in this world. And then bees, of course. You know, they're my arched men, nemesis. Bees. Bees? Do you want one more? Do you want one more? Of course we do.
还会说脱口秀，你知道的，比如你应该讲点你的脱口秀。哦，我有，哦，真的吗？哦，哦，对，哦，哦，对，哦，哦，对。你想来点正在彩排的段子吗？真的吗？芥末对蜜蜂说了什么？哈。给我点时间。哦，沙恩。是芥末。你真的很便宜。
Okay. What does an Irishman call 66% of a piece of poo? Huh. Oh, that's two-thirds of something. Two-thirds. That's right. Oh, that's good. There we go.
哦，因为，你知道的，里面有很多东西都贴近我的心。你知道吗？对。伪硬汉谈话。对。双关语。还有那个未被充分利用的寿司芥末，你知道的。对。
Nice, J.B. Yeah, thanks. Two-thirds. Well, that's like a combination. That's like a hybrid of a... Here we go. What's the opposite of a hybrid? I can't even think of it.
我只是觉得它在这个世界上没有得到公平的对待。还有蜜蜂，当然。你知道，它们是我最大的死敌，克星。蜜蜂。蜜蜂？你还想要一个吗？你还想要一个吗？当然。
Gas burning? No, that would be a hybrid. That would be a... Bibrate? No. Not at all. No. No.
好吧。爱尔兰人把三分之二的大便叫什么？哈。哦，那是某事的三分之二。三分之二。没错。哦，这挺好。我们就这样吧。
What are you fucking talking about? Just like a hybrid joke of two... Well, how about... Maybe you were going towards like, you know, You know, you know, you got those airplanes with the jets and then the other planes that don't have the jets. Oh, that's good. Those are like, bye, bye, brain, bye, bye, bye, bye. Smartless.
不错，J.B。对，谢谢。三分之二。嗯，这就像一个组合。这就像一个……的杂交品种。我们开始吧。杂交的反义词是什么？我都想不出来了。
Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic. by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbico, and Michael Grant Terry. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
燃油的？不，那是混动。那会是……振动器？完全不是。不。不。你在胡说八道些什么？就像一个将两种……结合的笑话。好吧，也许你的方向是，你知道的，你知道的，你有那种带喷气发动机的飞机，然后还有不带喷气发动机的其他飞机。哦，那挺好。就像，拜拜，大脑，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。Smartless。Smartless是100%纯天然的，由罗伯特·阿尔贾夫、本内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里制作。Smartless。本集还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。